hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute leute leute ihr
habt den titel gelesen und denkt
wahrscheinlich dass bestimmt klick beck
aber nein ist es nicht denn meine
homebase von reiner schick haben mir ein
iphone iks geschenk deshalb steht hier
auch werbe video dazu müsst ihr aber
wissen ich habe das einfach nix
willkommen ist kriegt kein geld dafür
dass ich sage dass ihr produkt toll ist
oder so aber es ist nun mal voll
geschrieben dass wenn man ein produkt
was über dem wert von 1.000 euro ist das
video als werbevideo kennzeichnet und
wie ihr vielleicht wisst ist das iphone
ist so ein gerät ja rainer schild habe
ich gesagt was die machen sagen sie
schildert ihre schilder ja sogar um die
schlossstädter den supermarkt gehen
sogar bereit später wenn die man
natürlich keine preisschilder sondern
sie machen super tough steht ihr drauf
hotel mit denen anscheinend das iphone
alles aushält beziehungsweise natürlich
nicht wirklich alles weil geht nicht
aber drops aus mindestens drei metern
höhe
dann kannst du ein iphone aus drei
metern höhe runterfallen lassen und ist
garantiert dass nichts passiert machen
wir das ganze mal hier auf wobei erst
mal mein iphone mix aus alter das ist es
praxis dazu erst einmal ausreichend
erstmal kraft keine vor sei eindeutig
natürlichen ausgefragt
glaubt ihr wirklich könnte warten dass
auszupacken das paket das rennen schickt
mir geschickt hat und passt halt einmal
so ein mod cayston und banken deren
rückseite dann halt einmal für beck
protection für die glasrückseite vom
iphone links wegen kabellosen laden und
die vorderseite das packe ich jetzt
alles drauf und hat man jetzt hier jetzt
lebende oberfläche und jetzt muss muss
die ziemlich genau anbringen
das kriege ich hin auf den ersten
versuch ja kommen so sieht gut aus oder
was denkst du ja es gibt ja also jetzt
muss man in luftblasen raus drücken
alle luftblasen sind draußen jetzt muss
man hier die rückseite noch abziehen
nun hat jetzt auch den ok rückseite clip
dran
ich habe gerade irgendwo ein tuch
gesucht aber es ist ja auch einfach ist
dabei der sogar noch so ein sticker da
weiß habe ich jetzt bei rückseite nicht
macht haben dich geht man hätte jetzt
hat er sich sofort mit ihr kann man den
staub wegziehen
ziel ist es weiter und die vorderseite
hier schwer mit dem cup out für die
seite wird wieder abgezogen weil mir
ganz normale sachen abzuziehen oder
leute jetzt irritiert auch noch fährt
glaube ich glaube ganz gut getroffen
wir machen mal super mario rang abläuft
ist schön hell und gesagt jetzt bringe
ich das nochmal an dritte gut sein dass
studieren.de groß es ist echt wenig
folie sieht man nicht so wirklich krass
dass da so eine folie vor allem die
folie handy hat die jetzt vorne und
hinten die folien auf ja gut da sieht
man dass man nichts sieht durch
schneider jetzt ja auch das moc casemod
cage modifizierbar ist da kann man auch
kameralinsen und so was dran schrauben
und da setzt sich leicht das gute stück
rain für die hülle ist sauber das kennen
die kommt rein
sitzt ja sitzt ja sonst nichts zu machen
du machst mir was das ist ganz tritt das
muss einfach machen leute kommen mit der
ich leite das sollte eigentlich gerade
nur so ein lockerer wird sein so als
geld das wir jetzt anfangen
aber das waren wahrscheinlich schon drei
meter höhe man kann natürlich sagen die
will hat hier sehr gut absorbiert an der
ecke hat natürlich ein bisschen was
abbekommen ich heute ohne spaß leute
einfach nur das handy so halos geht bis
in die luft werfen und ich habe
irgendwie vorher hochgeworfen das
wahlprogramm zurück ist nicht
kaputtgehen lebens
ich will aufhören wir bauen jetzt
vielleicht das dosenwerfen auch wenn sie
ein eigenes album das ich mein eigenes
ein was passiert ist es ist kein so was
kaputt geht ist so unangenehm wir sind
einfach überall leute warten also die
verpackten weil spätestens dann bleibt
es auf jeden fall stehen und gucken
deshalb warten wir kurz ableite dieses
iphone ist seit jahren ein hintergrund
werde ich jetzt auf die dosen werfen wer
weiß vielleicht kann ich ja alle auf
einer 8 323 gesehen dass das nicht so
richtig schön so auf die bank gebaut
oben drüber war das gerade streitet
alles ab grund also die drei stehen ja
noch schiebt man dann zusammenbreche ja
so hat das ist doch krank was wir machen
ist klar wenn wir am ende holen wir mal
das handy aus der hülle raus und aus den
folien und gucken wie so der gesamte
schaden ist aktuell kann ich wieder auf
der vorder noch auf der rückseite
irgendwas erkennen und das waren schon
so drei aktionen bei den handy durchaus
mal kaputt gehen könnte auch die kamera
ist unbeschadet soweit deshalb bist du
jetzt sagen sie was aber machen
sebastian jetzt auch am stab für die
aktion auf die passende jacke an und
wägen dekadenz die hülle der ist eine
super hülle aus die das buch
[Applaus]
ok bis auf zwei alle abgründe die leute
die diese hülle herstellen war dem handy
passiert nächstes jahr so einer ganz
starken hülle
wir haben uns das geschickt haben wir
uns mal austesten grüne und was macht ja
nichts wird also das case sieht hatte
schon bessere tage rein optisch erlebte
er gibt ja auch hier oben siehst du das
das ist so viel farbe abbekommen haben
wir müssen dagegen gesetzt dass die
farbe von der bank abgeben also zwei
stehen noch du kannst du jetzt entweder
schaffen gleich zu ziehen wurde aber ich
bin der iphone-apps dosenwerfen champion
man fragt sich wirklich was man
eigentlich so macht zu kurz zu fahren
können und schwingt sie viel erfolg also
eigentlich nicht eine steht noch ein
steht noch das abitur
wie geht's dir mal gras alterswehr das
gab das noch umfeld das war die schirme
dieser gewonnen
wir machen jetzt folgendes und zwar
hatten wir diesen müll einmal rein
das heißt dass handys nicht in den müll
fällt sondern sind titel
wir probieren jetzt damit wir so spielen
auch wieder von der gleichen linie und
leute auch wenn das ganze jetzt mies
abgehoben wird weil wir das mit so einem
teuren handy machen
ich hätte das ja in die heute nicht
wenig testen würde versteht ihr also
musste ich noch nicht ich muss das
machen einmal darf ich vertrau halt
einfach mit dem hersteller bisher hat
sie auch alles gut funktioniert wird der
film jetzt weiter
allerdings macht alles ganz soll ich
einfach nochmal machen und bis bissig
treffer und dann bist du dann versuche
damit wenn wir da nicht treffen
dann brechen wir ab okay weil ich kann
das nicht mit jedem wurf schneller
so jetzt leute kann ich schaffen letzter
wurf
das hat richtig eklig gekommen
das waren klickten von ein jogger das
licht angemacht bei woche ist einfach
durch den matsch und pferde alles
gezogen wird aber es geht immer noch gut
du bist dran war das neue iphone ixia
und wir haben das gerade genommen und
damit dosenwerfen geschieht weil macht
spaß auf jeden fall ziemlich angst aber
diese hülle hier so eine die das handy
der vorsitzende das kaputt gibt es quasi
haben das schon drei meter in die luft
geworfen
bisher ist noch nichts passiert seit
mein handy also wenn irgendwas passiert
dann aber wir machen schule aus
direkt im ersten versuch
wie geht es ihnen geht es ihm ja wort
aber er immer noch sein
diese liste ist so ismaik danach alter
aber dann hat ja echt die arbeits pensum
erfüllt bekommen
das war kraft knapp das war krass
letzter wunsch danach ist abbruch claims
ab dann sind wir einfach weiter schlecht
die basketballspieler beträgt mit licht
an halt machen nicht billiger das ewige
oh mein gott ich damit schlicht besser
sein
komplett daneben ok ab hau ab hau ab ob
wir wollen wir das mal unseren müll auch
packen jetzt das handy aus und ich bete
dass ich nichts übersehen haben und dass
es ihnen gut geht mir jetzt schon ein
bisschen platz zwischen der hülle und
den folien alter mein gott gibt ihr dass
die christ wie das ist kino das fest
gerade so aus der box sind
das hätte nicht gerade zwei absolute
toten kann mit dosenbier von basketball
gespielt und
zur vorschau auf die kanten absolut ohne
schaden soweit ich das hier erkennen
kann vorderseite auch komplett sauber
ich dachte dass wir so ein kleiner
haarriss aber war es auch nicht dass es
echt wie aus der box geholt als ich muss
sagen rainer schild wahrscheinlich hält
den wahrscheinlich gerade ein stein von
herzen und mir auch weil erstens ihr
produkt funktioniert und 21 mal ein
iphone ist noch ganz ja ich hoffe dass
wieder durchgefallen war echt 1 der
kraft drin wie das weiß nicht ob ich
schon mal sowas gemacht habe aber ja
fällt euch gefallen hat und das sehr
gern ein like da ich hoffe dass jetzt
nicht irgendwie auch sozial oder so was
wir gemacht haben wir haben einfach
geglaubt an die kraft der hülle und dann
sehen was beim nächsten mal wieder ich
packe ich ein paar links tor entschieden
die beschreibung bis dahin und ich bin
fertig mit den nerven leute